hello folks today a little bit alone I
gave my son the day off because I gave
my son
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and Executive even later
hello Lolo
hello hello can everybody hear me
can you hear me now
can you hear me okay okay let me begin
again if you can hear me please send me
a note if you can't hear me if something
gets interrupted okay okay let's begin
again anyways what I was saying for
those who didn't hear me I gave my son
the rest the day off and that's because
I want to talk about a subject which is
the ether okay and and I was saying that
the ether and another counterbalance to
that which are the four primary elements
you know they were discussed together
with other subjects for by many cultures
and in different regions of the planet
and and one thing that has happened over
the years is that we lost we dropped the
ball we stopped talking about these
things in a meaningful way in other
words the people who are not talking
about it about these things are the
people who should be talking about it
which are the scientists which are the
physicists and the people who are
actually talking about it and more in a
historical sense are the philosophers
and in the last two thousand years for
what I can tell at least if you go to
the Stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
etc I am made any progress essentially
you know we're still stuck with Plato
and Aristotle so there's been little
progress and let me put a little comment
which I liked I read it in a while doing
my research and I kind of liked it
because it summarizes exactly what has
happened over the centuries from say the
Greeks to our days you know we really
dropped the ball and here's the
statement here's what this guy says and
he says the purpose of me but
if I can the Parmenides of Plato belongs
to a stage of philosophy which has
passed the way absolutely love that
statement because I think it summarizes
quite a bit at first we read it with a
purity and Aquarian or historical
interest and with difficulty throw
ourselves back into a state of the hue
of the human mind in which unity and
being occupied the attention of
philosophers they were concerned about
these things right Plato is carrying on
a process which is not either useless or
unnecessary in any age of philosophy we
fail to understand him because we do not
realize that the questions which he is
discussing could have had any value or
importance we suppose them to be like
the speculations of some of the school
men which ended nothing but in truth he
is trying to get rid of the stumbling
blocks of thought which beset his
contemporaries and also be said beseech
curse current content our contemporaries
if they remain on examined as in a
mathematical demonstration all that
flows from them is affected and the air
pervades knowledge far and wide and I
like these statements especially the
first one the last one if it belongs to
stage of philosophy which has passed
away and if they remain not answered if
we examine or an unanswered if we don't
do something about all this they form
the foundations and it's going to affect
what it says there all that flows from
them is affected and the error pervades
knowledge far and wide absolutely love
that's that synthesis and and so the
question here is you know what are these
the moderns doing about this and the
answer is they're not doing anything
we're still we still don't know here I
have
you have my one of my books of physics
when I was in I think in high school
this is this is a long time ago and when
I read it you know in the first few
pages I find no mention of what an
object is what things are made of we
don't know what motion is there's no
definition obviously there's no
definition of distance or location we
don't know what exists means and these
words are used subsequently throughout
the book indirectly or directly in one
way or another and it's like we have we
have no idea what these words mean or
you know how to use them we think we
know because we say object and everybody
said I know what he's talking about
emotion yeah I know what he's talking
about and we don't because nobody has
defined these words and it turns out
that the Greeks among them spent a lot
of time on them they spent a lot of time
debating and even though we have
fragments from what they wrote we can
get a pretty good picture that there was
a big debate going on and
intergenerational debate going on
between them but it doesn't start there
when I look at when I look at where some
of these notions came from the earliest
I can see is about the sixth century BC
okay 600 years before Christ that's when
some people started writing about these
subjects now the first thing that comes
to my mind is that you know there was an
oral tradition before then and then I
don't think these concepts were born in
the sixth century perhaps if if we could
travel in time we would go back and find
out that some little old guy out there
that is not even mentioned in history
was probably the originator of some of
these ideas they were passed on along
from generation to generation and
eventually someone wrote him down and
the guy who we credit today is the guy
who wrote him down but they were
probably not the originators but again
that's that's a trivial issue the
question is that these people were
Wald in analyzing the nature of the
universe and one of the first examples
that I find or one of the first notions
of what things are comprised of and
you've probably heard it you know earth
fire air and water and here I find one
instance and it comes from the
Upanishads and there sank Sanskrit texts
that underlie both Hinduism and Buddhism
and this is the statement says from this
very self did space come into being from
space air from air fire from fire the
waters from the waters the earth from
the earth plants from plants food and
from food man ok so that's about the
first statement that you get in history
relating to at least the four primary
elements now it turns out that this is
the sixth century BC and that's an
estimate this is not ground in stone
there are debates on when the Upanishads
were written in the West we get mr.
what's-his-name
in pedal cleese see if I can find him
here better please and he says the
following you can see the date there
when he was approximately born in the
5th century there and he came up with a
notion of air water earth and Fire he's
the first one to propose that and in
modern days you know you can relate
those two gas liquid solid and what we
could call energy or plasma they didn't
know what fire was they just thought it
was some kind of basic element and side
here and what characteristics these
elements have for him
they were simple eternal unchanging
change is the result of the mixed
separation of these elements and divine
powers bring about mixture but the
divine powers our love which blends
which brings together and separation is
caused by strife so we have these two
major deities these two things that
belong to the gods
when is love the other one is strife
love and war and one produces
friendliness mixture blending blending
and the other one creates separation and
you know war people hostility right and
as you can see what's missing there and
again we're talking about 500 years BC
what's missing there is the ether or you
could call it space or whatever was out
there in space some kind of element some
kind of smoke some kind of spirit
whatever was out there it's kind of
missing from his from his listing of
elements but he was referring really to
the material elements okay one of the
guys that comes in next and and it
expands upon this is Parmenides and
Parmenides says the following and again
he erode in in poems right he says and
there's only one poem from him okay that
survives the rest that we know from
Parmenides comes from other Greeks who
over the centuries quote in him among
them Plato and I think Aristotle as well
and so this is the only fragment we have
heat and in those days it was customary
to write in poetry so not only did you
have to make sense of the universe but
you had to put in some poetic form like
you know if you look at the Iliad and
the Odyssey written in poet in a poetic
manner so what does Parmenides say there
is a gate of by the way Parmenides the
reason he can say all this with a
certain authority
is what precedes this the the longer
part of the story says that he was taken
by a goddess to see all these things he
was shown the truth of the world that
what is real so he came back after that
you know every one of these trips he
comes back and now he can tell us with
authority that this is what the gods
intended and what they they have up
there there is the gate that divides the
paths of night and day in a lintel and a
threshold of stone delimited from above
and below it erected in the ether right
neither now is closed by large shutters
you will know the ethers nature and in
the ether all the signs and the unseen
works of the pure torch of the brilliant
Sun and from whence they came to be and
you will learn the wandering works of
the round-eyed moon and its nature and
you will know to the surrounding heaven
both once it grew and how necessity
directing it bounded to furnish the
limits of the Stars and in the next
fragment he says how the Earth and Sun
and Moon and the shared ether and the
heavenly milk and Olympus outermost he
brings into into the picture the ether
and the ether heated he does not define
it very well he's going through this
trip who knows what ken drugs they use
in those days he goes through this trip
and and he comes back and he says the
ether okay there's something out there
called the ether well this is later
formalized by let's heapin see it here
this is formalized by mr. annex a gross
game and annex a grass lived about the
same time and he says erin ether covered
all things so it gets a little more
technical here here the ether covers all
things both being on
for these are the greatest among all
things both in amount and enlarged nests
so we have a better idea now of what the
ether might be it's something that
covers all things okay so the ether was
kicked around and and so one of the
issues that came around is you know what
is the ether what do we mean by this and
someone is gonna define this and today
we have an idea what it means it says
the word ether in Greek meant to burn to
incinerate to shine so it had to do with
fire it was like a godly fire a heavenly
fire holy fire and it's a conceived as a
pure form of fire okay and it's a
substance of which the stars and planets
are made according to the Greeks okay so
this was the idea that was developing
there was this mist this thing out there
called the ether and that kind of was a
counterbalance to the two what was here
which was the fire the water the air and
the earth so so you had the ether out
there and these four elements down here
and more or less that's how eventually
this develops and is transmitted from
generation to generation we have Plato
and he talks about the four elements
okay he reinforces his inter up in the
revolution let me make this a little
bigger so I can see it in the revolution
of the universe are comprehended all the
four elements and this being circular
and having a tendency to come together
compresses everything and will not allow
any place to be left void so it covers
everything okay wherefore also fire
above all things penetrates everywhere
in air next as being next in rarity of
the elements and the
to other elements in like manner
penetrate according to their degrees of
rarity for those things which Arkham
composed of the largest particles have
the largest void left in their
composition and those which are composed
of the smallest particles have the least
and the contraction caused by the
compression thrust the smaller particles
into the interstitials of the larger and
thus when the small parts are placed
side by side with a larger and the
lesser divide the greater and the
greater unite the lesser all the
elements are borne up and down and
hither and thither towards the their own
places for the change in the size of
each changes its position in space so
he's talking about size and you know how
these particles have size and they kind
of interfere with each other and these
call and these causes generate an
inequality which is always maintained
and is continually creating a perpetual
motion of the elements in all time okay
and he continues I think I have another
quote from him here he says I think he
finds it here he says there are diverse
kind there are diverse kinds of fire
there are for example first flame and
secondly those emanations of flame which
do not burn but only give light to the
eyes these were the notions that they
had thirdly the remains of fire which
are seen in red hot embers after the
flame has been extinguished
there are similar differences in the air
of which the translucent kind is called
the ether and the most turbid sword'
mist and darkness what what he's saying
is that the ether is somewhere in here
on earth ok-hee it's among the these
four elements but he still hasn't quite
define what this ether is he's just
throwing this around it's not until we
get to Aristotle that we get a more
formalized idea of what this ether
becomes
and what Aristotle does essentially is
he puts the ether into outer space
beyond the moon specifically he's saying
the moon goes around the earth and
Beyond the moon that's where the ether
is the ether has nothing to do with the
four elements as Plato suggested and the
four elements have nothing to do with
the ether okay this is what Aristotle is
gonna come up with get this so Aristotle
says the following he says
there can be no contrary motion to the
circular nature scene seems to just let
me get this a little bigger justly to
have exempted from contraries the body
ether which has to be ungenerous
indestructible so according to Aristotle
is it's something really that has no
origin and cannot be destroyed no
beginning no end no alpha no Omega the
primary body is eternal and not subject
to increase or diminution but unchanging
and alterable and unmodified the primary
body is something else beyond earth fire
air and water
they gave the highest place a name of
its own and he calls it the ether but
he's not gonna use that word by the way
he only mentions it a couple times here
derive from the fact that it runs always
for an eternity of time it's a flame
that runs forever and it's a grass he's
referring to the other fellow of his
predecessor
however scandalous limas uses this name
taking ether as equivalent to fire so
what Aristotle does he and he I think
he's gonna do that in the next quote
here and it says well it's a summary of
what Aristotle said he wrote a lot the
element of the Stars fills the entire
heavenly region from first heaven to the
moon first heaven is beyond the moon so
from the first heaven to the moon it is
never to be found in the region occupied
by the other four elements it's divine
eternal unchanging and has circular
motion with which he explains celestial
motion they were aware that you know the
earth was going around the Sun or the
Sun around the earth one other - and it
was all circular they it was like
recurrent every day the same thing
happens so they figured out their
circular motion and they're saying
that's due to the ether at least
Aristotle is saying that okay so the
ether now is being transformed from
an original idea that was some kind of
mist out there that was maybe in between
fire and air and earth and water and now
Aristotle puts it way beyond the earth
he says down here there's no each of the
ethers out there okay so he's the first
one to kind of separate these these
notions or these concepts so we get to
mr. Crispus again Aristotle is uh what
is it like third century BC for third
and fourth here we get to the 3rd
century BC maybe 50 years later yeah
Aristotle was Alexander the Great's
teacher and he died about the same time
they died a 323 BC so we're talking
about really the 4th century here we get
to the 3rd century and we have Crispus
and he's got this stoic idea and the
stories were supposedly materialist
because they believe that a body that
exists is one that can be acted upon or
that can act upon another one so only
those things that can interface
physically those are the ones that
according to the Stoics existed and that
means that they and you might say well
you know did love exist well they turned
a lot of these things into solids into
physical things and they said yeah love
exists because you know it's a it's a
body and so they have so the question is
a lot of these things are very nebulous
because they turn some concepts into
objects and then they say see it can act
upon something so the the Stoics had had
a little bit of a contradiction there
and then Crispus is the guy who invents
the pluma and the pneuma is essentially
the ether in in other words it's the
breath of the gods it's the mist
that comes out of there
holiness out of their magic wands and
it's a fairy air or breath that gives
life's to things where the word is
closely linked to the ether okay and no
- here is where they differ with the you
Epicureans
who maintain that like Democritus who
was not a pkuran or even a story he came
before that of those times but
Democritus is famous for saying you know
that there's this indivisible which
we're going to call the atom that's what
the word atom means indivisible and so
you saw this universe as a bunch of
discrete little balls pretty much like
the quantum mechanics fellows of today
right and here's where these guys the
storage this disagree with them they say
look it's not that there's all these
little particles they're saying there's
this Numa and the Puma is continuous
okay so we have the continuous guys
against the discreet guys essentially
that's the separation there and that's
where a Crispus kind comes up with this
notion and it's the same Numa that is
going to be identified with the ether
they said look we've already discuss
that we already invented the ether now
he calls it the pluma which is
essentially a breath of life right that
comes from the gods but here's the
critical point the critical point is now
the ether takes on more a religious
character now we're going to talk about
the relationship of Numa in terms of the
soul so he says okay I don't have it
there but essentially he's the first guy
who begins talking more about how the
Numa is the breath of life or a theory
life theory theory breath that the gods
are imbuing matter with us
specifically us living matter
specifically even though the room
apparently you know isn't everything
that's in the stones it's in everything
but in us it gives us life and what is
the Puma well it's gonna be the soul
eventually that's gonna be
you've evolved into it's going to
develop into the soul okay and about 400
years later now we're talking about the
Christian era
it gets more the ether gets more and
more religious okay if you can read that
there let me make it a little bigger
wise men that's what plotting us says he
says Wiseman called this body and he's
referring to the ether here the vehicle
of the soul okay so he's gonna take this
ether that was out beyond the moon put
out there by Aristotle he's gonna bring
it in he says no look this ether is
really what makes us live what makes us
breathe it's it's the foundation of our
soul okay so now the ether is gonna
leave physics a little bit and leave the
scientific path it was in and it's gonna
come more into the religious path
they're gonna talk more about the soul
in terms of the ether and he says
vehicle of the soul that is an ethereal
body is taken out of the ether and he's
referring to plate to Aristotle's ether
okay but he says that you know that mist
is now coming to earth the stone which
the Philosopher's do seek is an
indivisible and impalpable spirit stars
indicate rather than cause phenomena
such as the inclinations and qualities
of humans stars what are he what is he
referring to well he's getting it a
little bit into astrology here we're
starting to not only talk about the
souls of men but about how the stars
affect man and why because the ether in
which the stars bathe or swim or
whatever it goes through the stars
through the planets and then comes to us
and so we have this influence from the
stars okay and so now we're starting to
get again people are more concerned
about the soul and how the ether makes
its way to us to our to our hearts or to
our stomachs or whatever they're our
brains and
and fills us with this life-giving magic
and it's also what makes us live okay so
the ether has to do more now not so much
with matter with the physical with a
scientific positive path that we could
have followed now as we approach the
dark ages it's getting more into you
know Christianity into what does it do
for the soul or how it's related to the
soul and we get to mister Marciano's
fifth-century here and again he blesses
fire water and air in fact he draws it I
don't know if you can see that there let
me make it bigger just for a second so
that you can see it better but he's got
water that's aqua that's water outside
he's got air inside he's I think this is
either terra or fire it's not very clear
what he wrote there but essentially he's
saying there are concentric circles of
all this stuff right oh there's
concentric circles of each one of these
chemical elements but he says yeah
everything is that we still were
thinking terms of fire water earth and
air right and he just says you know that
there's these concentric circles of
these elements around the earth and but
he doesn't get rid of the ether quite
the contrary he he's gonna take the
ether and also put it in line with
Christianity with God with with the
Bible right and so he's got to make
sense of what Plato and Aristotle all
these guys are saying at the same time
he had to fit it within religion and
that's that's where how ether is now
progressing and he says entire zodiac
permanent wrote a firmament rotates
around Earth so he's got now we're
getting into this astrological world
where the stars not only influence us
but we they realize that you know that
the earth throughout the year passes
through different
the latians so now they're beginning to
say well you know these stars we're here
in March there again in March so now
they see a cycle and they're saying you
know the guy who's born around this time
he's being influenced by these stars
because again the ether was coming from
the stars it was penetrating the space
between the moon and the earth it was
reaching our brains and doing something
to us whoever was born on that day was
being influenced by that ether okay
and it says ether is the fifth medium
around which Sun Moon planets and stars
of the zodiac circle and rotation of the
universe shapes elements into spheres
okay so now we we get this perfect
geometric figure called a sphere why is
it a sphere well because you know so
many so much circling you know II kind
of polishes and you know forms it into a
circular form that was the notion these
people had and you can see they they do
try to draw circles and the circle and
the sphere become prominent within this
whole astrology religion that is being
born here okay and I'm gonna skip a
couple steps because I have some
material to cover so I'll jump directly
to this individual and he lives about a
thousand years later there were people
in between you've got st. Augustine you
got John the grammarian there there's
several people in between there but they
all pretty much say the same thing they
take the ether they put it in terms of
religion in terms of astrology and by
the time you reach what the 15th century
here ad you start mixing it with another
religion it's being born which is the
chemistry the mixture of what they
called the I forgot the word alchemy
they start mixing chemicals and now that
also comes into play because of the four
elements because now they discover that
there's also sulfur and Mercury
and they have kind of different
properties and they kind of separate
them from the traditional four so
there's these four plus so four sulfur
and Mercury and of course they're also
gonna include salt eventually right and
here's this Pacino
that's his name Italian guy as you can
see and let me see if I make it a little
bigger it says the Maggie the
Zoroastrians right call this body the
vehicle of the soul again repeating to
some degree what others had already gone
through right the same train of thought
caught the vehicle of the soul that is
the ethereal body received from the
ether the souls immortal garment it is
round yeah you know we have circular
spherical they like those that shape it
is round and partly because it roundness
has this infinity quality to it you can
run around it forever right it is round
in its natural shape because of the
roundness of the cereal region but it's
it transforms itself into our angular
human shape when it enters the human
body and restores itself to its former
shape when it departs from it the ether
comes in here you know in its round but
then it's in the human body it takes the
shape of the body or get some different
shape whatever throughout life when you
die it goes back to where it was and
here's the synthesis which I got because
there's a lot of reading material a
spiritual entity arriving from the star
serves as the vehicle for the soul that
enters the hearts of humans upon birth
this ethereal medium the tip determines
an individual's horoscope and fate okay
so it determines your future so you
better be born on the right date ask
your mother
and the soul is initially round deforms
after it enters a body and round again
when we die okay so that's the cycle of
the ether within your body
okay then and by the way this Alchemist
he was one of the early guys who could
I tried to do it scientifically and so
he was quite popular and respected in
his day within the scientific community
of the day okay and some of this also
had to do you keep always this in mind
it had to do with medicine people who
had ailments they would come to see
these guys because these were the
physicians of the day they were the
witch doctors in the cities and people
would visit them and say look you know I
got it my ear hurts or my chest hurts
and the guy would mix maybe I don't know
mercury with salt and say drink this
it'll cure all your ills and they did
these kinds of thing they were
alchemists they were mixing things in
their lab they were mad scientist's and
you know the basement working in the
basement and and so they came up with
these ideas based on some of the things
that they did in the labs okay and
here's another one from mr. Pacino and
he says he's getting more philosophical
about it here the stone is a fifth
separated from four in other words the
four elements the stone he's gonna talk
about you gonna talk about the ether
which is the fifth stone and by the way
if I get it correctly Aristotle did not
consider it the fifth element the
quintessential he considered it the
first element the other four came later
here we have it in Reverse
the stone is a fifth separated from four
it is the bond of the elements the
medium and the chain which has made the
elements of God agree and which is the
which in the womb of the earth
conglutination sulfur and Mercury into a
metallic bodies such as such a bond is
in invisible okay so so he's gonna mix
them but he's gonna say that the the
thing that's gonna mix it it's gonna
serve as the thing that melts him and
that puts them together or that blends
them together is an invisible thing
that's and again the ether is invisible
okay
does all kinds of things the spirit and
that's what he's gonna call it and he's
gonna separate spirit from soul keep
this in mind okay the spirit is also the
tie of the soul and the body he says you
know in other words a body is tied to
the soul through the spirit it's the
spirit that's gonna form the soul in
your body okay so the spirit is separate
from the soul and as it as it were the
ethereal chariot or vehicle of the soul
which spreads abroad the virtue of the
soul through the whole body
you may also understand the four
elements when the philosophers affirm
that the went and when the philosophers
got last year which you may also
understand the four elements when the
philosophers affirm that the stone
consists of body spirit and soul so he
separates those okay for the water is
spirit also air the middle fire as I may
say is spirit the earth we call not
spirit but body because it is the
retainer the matter and the seat of the
other elements okay so what Pacino is
introducing here again he's he's a an
astrologer he's an alchemist and
obviously a philosopher in the sense in
the traditional photonic or Greek sense
okay and he separates the spirit from
the soul and the soul from the body okay
and he says that the spirit when the
soul comes in where I'm sorry yeah when
the soul comes in where the ether comes
in william enters your body it's a soul
but it's the spirit that's gonna form
the soul inside your body so now that
your your soul has has a form inside
your body now you die and both the
spirit and the soul leave your body
okay now the spirit and soul both leave
your body the spirit goes back to God
and the soul this dissipates I think
that's the weight or maybe it's the
other way around let me see I think
get it here no I've got it after that
I've got it with Paracelsus okay but I
know that one of those two can't
remember which now but the spirit goes
back to God and that's the guy that
molded the soul and the soul oh yeah and
that in the soul recovers its ethereal
body or a form which is round so so this
is the cycle the cycle is ether
penetrates your body and it comes in as
a circular or rounded shape inside your
body the spirit molds it so that this
the soul now takes on the body the shape
of your body or maybe some other shape
who knows and now when you died both the
spirit and the soul leave the soul goes
back to God the spirit goes back to God
but the soul the soul goes back to what
it was which is the shape of the ether
roundness and the spirit becomes this is
the funny part the spirit becomes the
nothingness of God so God sends
nothingness to mold your soul when
you're done with the spirit goes back to
God becomes nothing again that was the
the notions these people created very
complex in a sense but this what was
going through their minds one thing and
the other one is that as you can see
they're relating at ever more evermore
into religion into the soul they forget
about what the ether is or whether it's
walls or what the elements are made out
of they're just concerned about the soul
and part of that has to do with again
with medicine the fact that people would
visit them and they had to create these
philosophies to find out you know how
they were going to cure people they had
a real problem in front of them they try
to solve it with some of these
explanations and we arrived to someone
who came just a short while afterwards
and asked Paracelsus and he's a quite
more known than this previous guy the
Pacino and Paracelsus says matter is
comprised of fire water air and earth
okay so everybody believed in this idea
even up to the sixteenth century I would
say right and beyond ether is the stuff
of starlight and souls again tying
what's out there in the stars all these
planets all these stars are made out of
ether and that same stuff is what we're
made or our souls are made out of right
eat matter and ether are both substances
so the ether is now turned into a
substance or at least he claims that it
is without saying what a substance is
but he's thinking of the ether is
something material they visualize as far
as I can tell as a mist as some some
kind of vapor that's I think how they
visualize this and they say this vapor
this holy vapor or material this the
smoke comes from beyond the stars
bringing all the Starlight all this
stuff from the stars into our body and
because it comes from the stars we are
influenced by the stars you heard of the
flu you know in fact I had the flu twice
this year terrible stuff yeah I still
have a little bit of cough and and we
have you know you know we have these and
I forgot forgot my train of thought
there anyways these people had to relate
it to the soul and again they had to
relate it to health because they had to
cure people and so they tied the ether
to the soul and also said you know we oh
I was saying about the influenza that
you caught the flu and calls from the
word comes from the word influenza which
means that you are influenced what were
you influenced by the stars the it will
all relate it to the ether the ether
came from the stars and if you got a
cold it was because you
were influenced by the Stars and what
could else could that be if not the
ether so it was all tied together this
this whole philosophy and it lasted many
centuries and by the way another
interesting point if you're interested
you know Ethiopia comes from the word
ether because the ether
really Ethiopian you know the word meant
burnt and Ethiopian means burnt face
they refer to black people as Ethiopians
in general and it came from the fact
that they had burned faces black faces
even there was a regiment in the
Revolutionary War around 1775 died by an
emo Dunsmore I think Lord Dunsmore he
was the last governor of Virginia and
this fellow in order to fight the
revolutionaries the Americans who were
trying to fight for their Liberty he was
a British guy so he said look we don't
have enough personnel so why don't we do
the following and he said you know put a
the note out there I guess was spread
through the grapevine and they said you
know any black what's the gain his
Liberty once again is freedom from their
plantation owners all he has to do is
join our regiment and so a lot of blacks
left their masters they thought it was a
good idea and they joined the regimen
the regiment was called Ethiopian
regiment because they were all black
faced and the notion of Ethiopian also
lasted all the way up to the Civil War
where was used as a polite way of
referring to blacks the term I'm black
I'm a black American did not exist at
the time and so they called him
Ethiopians you know blackface people who
were called Ethiopians and that term has
gone into disuse but Ethiopian means
blackface and it's got to do with burnt
face from the word burnt that that's
what ether means anyway he's getting
back here it says matter ether are both
substances ether
our soul okay it's identified where the
soul is initially chaotic spirit is what
gives it form ether returns to its
original form chaos so it goes back to
all this mess this this order after the
body dies meanwhile the immortal
quintessence or spirit that gave it form
becomes the nothingness of God so the
spirit goes back to God and the soul
goes not to heaven I guess we're maybe
it does because that was like a heaven
for them the soul goes back to where it
was which is the ether that forms the
mist that on which all the planets and
stars out there on which they rotate so
there's this medium called the ether it
you gotta think of it as maybe a wheel
firmament you know they're they're stuck
to this medium and this medium every now
and then comes to earth visits us goes
into our bodies as the soul and the
spirit comes over molds it shapes it
forms it now you die and one goes back
to God becomes nothing that nothingness
of God the other one goes back to being
a sphere of some kind and forms the
ether which is where the stars dwell so
that's in a nutshell what happened with
the ether up to that point and you might
think that you know well now we get into
the 17th century and you get to the
Scientific Revolution and you would
think that all these new guys you know
say well okay we're gonna let go of this
ether and we're gonna do some real
science they didn't hear we have mr.
Newton Isaac Newton and he has the
following this is long so I've got it in
like two pieces well open it up like
that he writes a letter to Robert Hooke
in 1678 look how late it is right
separate almost lates of 17th century
and he says let ABCD be a dense body
whether opaque or transparent EF gh by
the way it's gonna be here I'm gonna
show it in a second so do not despair
the outside of the uniform ether which
is within it if I klm the inside of the
uniform ether which is without it and
conceive the ether which is between fe f
GH and jklm to run through all the
intermediate degrees of density between
that of the two uniform ethers on either
side
this being supposed the Rays of the Sun
SBS K which passed by the edge of this
body between B and K ought in their
passage through the unequally dense
ether there to receive a ply from the
denser ether which is on that side
towards K and that the more bi and that
the more by how much they passed near to
the body and thereby to the scattered
through the space pqrst as by experience
they are found to be now the space
between the limits EFG H I K Elam I
shall call the space of the ethers
graduated rarity what did you say well
he says look here you have the Sun and
here you have the Rays and this is
passing by an object on the inside here
EFG H that's ether and on the outside I
KL m or jklm right
you have ether so these dotted lines are
the ether that surround any body he body
has ether on the inside and on the
outside okay and the way Newton saw this
is this ether has different densities
and the densities get closer to the edge
of the body and farther away they get
less that's a thinner right so when the
Rays of the Sun here we have light
coming around for example between the
ether on the inside between point F and
K it gets twisted on the inside because
the density of the ether is greater in
that area so it's the density of the
ether that bends the Rays of the Sun
that's how Newton envisioned it
originally
and you know people don't like to
mention that they're great Newton was
you know was talking about the ether
it's like you know what's this guy this
guy's in need eight days of the Greeks
he may no no progress instead he's
talking about the ether in the
seventeenth century this mathematician
who discovered gravity and all the laws
of motion all that so they had a hard
time and so they don't usually talk
about this very much okay but in his
book on optics which was published in
1730 right which is the next century
beginning of the next century shortly
before he died or I think it was
published after he died but he he did
publish it while he was alive I think
there 17:30 is uh perhaps another
edition and I'm not sure maybe it was
even published posthumously but this is
the issue the issue is where we have
this this is what he went Newton says in
optics the small so so we're talking
about you know you made some progress ed
well that was a 17th century here we
talking about the 18th century he's
still with the ether
he says the smallest of the the rays of
light may contribute very much to the
power of the agent by which they are
refracted and so if anyone should
suppose that ether like our air may
contain particles which endeavour to
recede from one another for I do not
know what this ether is and that it's
particles are exceedingly smaller than
those of air or even than those of light
so light is not the ether right the
exceeding smallness of its particles may
contribute to the greatness of the force
by which those particles may recede from
one another what Newton is saying that
there's a medium out there independent
of light and you can see it in that
picture in the previous picture here
right you can see it that if this is the
object and this is light the ether these
dotted lines are separate from the rays
of light okay so if light is made of
particles these particles are going
through the ether it's a different
medium ether is assuming
imagine it as a bunch of particles we
have this medium but light is a bunch of
other particles which because of their
size can go through the ether okay so
that's how he envisioned he envisioned
the corpuscles of light being separate
from the ether the medium through which
they travel in which obviously according
to Newton filled all of space okay so he
writes that in optics here right and I
have another thing on mr. Newton I think
no I don't that was it okay so
essentially the important part but here
is again that the particles that Newton
talks about the corpuscles that
according to him formed light they are
separate from the ether this notion this
idea is going to change completely by
the time we get to the 19th century and
you get people like Augustine friend now
the French researcher who tried to
figure out how polarization works and he
also tried to figure out and wrote
papers on how the slit experiment worked
so he's the guy who comes up with these
two ideas of the slit experiment of
explanations for him right and for
polarization and he was given quite a
few medals because of his dedication to
those two subjects but how did they see
it well starting starting with people
like Thomas Young and Eyre ago the other
French guy and friend now and onwards
they all started visualizing the ether
as the exact medium that vibrated and
light was a vibration of the ether
something that was not the same type of
ether that Newton was thinking of Newton
was saying look this ether is out there
there's this medium he probably
visualized it a bunch of particles but
these
these the the particles of light had the
ability to vibrate that ether and pass
through it so it didn't stop light in in
fact you know it permitted the the
passage of light because of the
differences in size and but it was that
same ether that went in great
concentrations in higher density that
bent the rays of light that was his
notion of how this worked
you can probably laugh at Newton today
but I think in that sense you got to
give him credit that at least it's poor
guy was trying to break his brain to
find out you know how this universe
worked and that I I have a lot of
respect for but again 19th century that
changes now the ether becomes the medium
that vibrates and that is light and here
we have I'll skip a couple here so that
we can move on here we have mr. Maxwell
okay and I think he's the guy who pretty
much states it in in the most
comprehensive way and again almost two
towards the end of the 19th century he
says in several parts of this treatise
an attempt has been made to explain
electromagnetic phenomena by means of
mechanical action transmitted from one
body to another by means of a medium
occupying the space between them okay
the undulatory met a theory of light
also assumes the existence of a medium
we have now to show that the properties
of the electromagnetic medium are
identical with those of the luminiferous
medium now there is he's saying the
famous luminiferous medium ether is the
vibrated light is the vibration of that
same medium they are one and the same
that's what max was saying what in 1873
that's how far in time we were still
talking about the ether in terms of
trying to explain light with it Newton
said you know the particles are going
through the ether Maxwell is saying no
it's the vibration
is the vibration of the ether there's
this medium out there well this kind of
all fell apart when mr. Michaelson Morni
they came up and they did a little
experiment as most of you probably know
and it's the e famous Michelson Morley
experiment on the Ethernet she
discovered that no matter how they put
their little device their detector
they didn't detect any ether out there
in space and no matter how they position
that there there was no preferential
direction of light light was not stopped
in any direction and they would have
they assumed that if the light had to
traverse the ether it would have been
bent like Newton suggested or even like
Maxwell and in a letter to Lord Rayleigh
he says the experiments on the relative
motion this Michelson writing the letter
and remember it's just a few years after
Maxwell wrote his treatise the
experiments on the relative motion of
the earth and ether have been completed
and a result decidedly negative ok the
expected deviation of the interference
fringes from the zero should have been
zero point four of a fridge the maximum
displacement was 0.02 and the average
much less than 0.01 and then not in the
right place a displacement is
proportional with the squares of the
relative velocities it follows that if
the ether does slip past the relative
velocity past the relative velocity is
less than 1/6 of the Earth's velocity
anyways he justifies to Lord Rayleigh
that in his opinion after taking all
these measurements and he did the
experiment by the way more than once ok
and he he wrote a couple papers not one
and in both instances in all instances
really he maintained that there is no
ether out there and so this kind of
destroyed Maxwell's idea that light
was the vibration of the ether and kind
of destroyed also Newton because Newton
says well you know light is going
through the ether and it's the density
of the ether that is pulling the ray of
light inwards and if there's no no ether
out there well these guys are talking in
vain because that means you know light
is not being bent by the ether and that
is not the vibration of the ether and so
Michelson really threw a wrench into the
workings of of the ether anyone who
mentioned the ether and who comes next
well we have mr. Einstein and he writes
a paper his famous paper of 1905 one of
the four papers that he writes that year
mirabilis under Ovilus and he says the
introduction of a luminiferous ether
will prove to be superfluous and as much
as the view here to be developed will
not require an absolute stationary space
and here he's talking about the
relationship to this mist that's out
there and he said there's no mist okay
we don't need it he says provided with
special properties nor assign a velocity
vector to a point of the empty space in
which electromagnetic processes take
place okay he writes that in there so he
he kind of gets in line with what
Michelson discovered and people getting
this idea had already made up their mind
that maybe there is no ether and so they
say well if there is no ether I bet I
can get in line with these people get on
the boat you know tow the party line and
say the same thing there is no ether but
I'd say saying you know I don't need it
I don't need the ether that's what he
says in 1905 but then he comes in 1920
and another famous paper of his the
where he talks to the faculty in Leiden
Germany and he says according to the
general theory of relativity which came
in 1916 1915 1916 space without ether is
unthinkable period we could
was stopped there for in such space
there would be no propagation of light
we got a little bit of a contradiction
on one hand he says you know I don't
need the ether now he's saying look you
know if we don't have an ether we don't
have any propagation of light he could
not make sense of the propagation of
light without some kind of medium and
that's he's going back to Maxwell he's
saying you know maybe this ether is the
vibration of the ether this lighted
light is the vibration of the ether and
so this is what he says in 1920 15 years
after he wrote this his first paper but
this ether may not be thought of and
endowed with with the quality
characteristic of ponderable media as
consisting of parts this is important
for all these people who say the ether
is made out of little particles okay it
doesn't consist of part in other words I
guess he's saying it's continues right
which may be tracked through time so you
cannot think of the ether as little
particles and he adds the idea of motion
may not be applied to it in other words
if the ether if if there is an ether out
there it's some kind of continuous
medium the Rope may be I don't know just
getting my hopes up here that's a
continuous medium it cannot be made of
particles and you cannot assign motion
to those particles you cannot say that
there's vibrating ether in the
background which is what quantum holds
today you know that there's this vacuum
this false vacuum energy whatever they
want to call it and they've got all
virtual particles coming in and out of
the void so so the current idea is that
there's some kind of energy ether out
there in space filling space they don't
want to mention the word because it's a
no-no it's taboo to mentioned the word
ether but that's what it is it's it's a
universe where space is filled with this
ether stuff but according to mr.
Einstein here 1920 right he says that
this ether
cannot be seen as made of discrete
particles that can move that vibrate or
whatever it's got to be seen as a
continuous medium and again none of his
ideas were taken seriously nobody
bothered to look at Einsteins ether they
it got buried in the ash heap of history
and today we use the ether quantum
mechanics uses the ether in the sense
that he that Einstein was negating the
way he was opposed he was saying you
know yeah
there is no bunch of particles out there
filling space which is currently the the
version that quantum uses they say yeah
the space is not only made of particles
but these particles come in from the
void whatever the void is and they make
themselves known or seen or detected
just to get the equations right then
they go back into nothingness
whatever nothingness is and so it's the
ether again and the ether hasn't died
it's still with us so so but I'm saying
raises a good point which is the same
point that Maxwell raises and says you
know how can I be the vibration of
nothing so so he had a problem with that
and so did Maxwell and so that everyone
since then you know that that has a
little bit of brain inside his head
you know everybody questions the same
thing how can the how can might be the
vibration of nothing and there's a lot
of people who hold that in fact they I
can't say it's the official stance but
laws of people in the mathematical
establishment say that it's the
vibration of nothing you will find that
in many places on the Internet
okay so what happened here mr. Bourne
comes in Max Born you've heard of him
and Max Born kind of resolves the whole
thing and he writes in a book that he
published in 1964 the Einstein's theory
of relativity and he says he doesn't say
it but this is a
synthesis that the wiki has of his book
or of his conclusions is since the
development of special relativity 1908
thereabouts theories using a substantial
ether fell out of use in modern physics
did they okay and were replaced by more
abstract models we went from objects to
concepts
that's essentially what mr. Bourne is
saying in different words we started
thinking of we stopped thinking of light
and electrons and whatever as being real
things and we started talking more about
you know these things as abstractions as
more like numbers you're not shaking a
particle corpuscle as Newton thought
about it you're you really have a wave
of probabilities probability wave or
whatever whatever that means what is a
probability wave well again and it's
like born says here they stop looking at
forget about the ether you know as
filled with particles forget about the
movement of something being light no no
but what we we're gonna talk about from
now on as the movement of numbers we're
gonna talk about the probability where
we can find how we can detect it and not
what is it
and that goes back to the statement I
made at the beginning here where you
know we lost this this idea that the
Greeks had in trying to elucidate you
know what is matter made out of
ultimately what is this invisible world
that makes us well we figured out more
or less that it's made out of atoms but
that's about as far as we got because
everything else is supernatural
irrational so realistic and you're born
is telling you why they moved from
concreteness to abstractness
they went into abstractions and since at
least the twenty since the time of max
form it's always been a very quite
abstract
you know it's a you read anything in
mathematical physics
it's totally abstract and they've harped
more on words like as energy mass and so
on which are all concepts force field
charge they're all concepts and that's
what they move around today and you say
well what is it energy what is mass what
is charge and they can't tell you
because they can't point to it they
can't tell you look like they can't
point to it like you point to a rock or
to a three year or to a dog they can't
do that they say look you got to take a
course at the University you understand
what I'm talking about and what I'm
talking about is mass and energy and
work and you know charge and field and
time and nobody has any idea what these
words mean because they're not even
defined properly so yeah we went into a
world of abstraction but undefined
abstractions that's important too okay
so is the ether dead because of this
well let me show you that it kind of
isn't here I have there's a couple of
these papers running around but I just
pulled one as an example
come on taking a long time to get up
there here's a paper written in what is
in 1998 it says an ether model based
upon a degenerate fermion fluid composed
primarily of electrons and positrons in
a negative energy state relative to the
null state or crew vacuum yeah false
vacuum this is the true vacuum its
proposed and its consequences are
explored for physics and cosmology the
model provides both insight and
quantitative results were a large number
of phenomena and he lists a bunch of
phenomena there later on a key
assumption is that the speed of light is
the Fermi velocity of the degenerate I
love the words that these guys use
electron positron plasma that dominates
the ether so has the ether died well no
people are still bringing it back to
life and again it's because people
cannot reconcile themselves to the fact
that you do that light or anything for
for that matter the electron cannot be
the vibration of nothing it's got to be
the vibration of something and you know
people say it's what are we gonna call
that something we'll call it the ether
and then the fight is well what is the
ether is it an ocean is it continues as
a discrete does it vibrate is it made of
tiny little particles like Newton said
and light goes through it and has the
ability to vibrate the ether as he goes
through it is it because of the size of
the particles that this one's bigger
than that one's smaller is that what it
is
so so people want to know what the ether
is it's like we haven't abandoned that
because no one has told us yet what
light is and when people say well the
light is a bunch of particles will call
them photons and you say okay I
understand then series the particle flow
of particles we all understand it right
no we know because it turns out when you
look at the word particle the word
particle doesn't mean corpuscle it
doesn't mean speck of dust doesn't mean
even a point in that sense the or a
geometric point a little ball or
whatever know the word particle me is is
a is a value okay it's a value and and
so you know this is this is where we
were at today and let me finish this
with one of our sister groups here that
does they called it physics and it's the
group we call the electric universe and
I'll split this up in two parts
says the real nature of light in man
this is by wall Thornton Thornhill and
he's one of the Guru's of the electric
universe and he says in my view the
crucial difference between the near
infinite speed of the electric force and
a relative bottle of light on any cosmic
scale is that the electric force is
longitudinal while light is an
oscillating transfer signal moving
slowly through a medium what medium
could he've possibly be referring to if
I can use a simple and our
light travels slowly like the transverse
ripples on a pond surface gravity
travels swiftly and Lajja tuned
Mangia to Domini like the speed of sound
in water once again this is at odds with
the it--with einstein's metaphysics
because it reinstates Maxwell's ether
Maxwell's electromagnetic Theory
requires a medium how can you wave
nothing and again people are concerned
about the waving of nothing there we
agree that we have to have something to
talk about waves and he adds the
Michelson Morley but basement experiment
was heralded as having lain to rest the
motion of an ether it didn't dayton
miller carried out far more rigorous
repeats of that experiment at different
locations and elevations he found a
residual which allowed him to conclude
that ponderable bodies like the earth
doing drag the ether with them he was
able to determine the relative motion of
the solar system with respect to the
ether so what is uh is mr. Thornhill
saying well he believes in the ether and
he's proposing the ether after all these
years electric universe is an ether
theory and there are other people who
obviously proposed the ether who are not
part of the electric universe the ether
is not dead and the main issue here is
what underlies what physical object
underlies light and from the ancients
we've got what is it from the Upanishads
we've got earth water air and fire and
then we added the ether and the ether
was put outside the moon and
[Music]
this ether was some kind of myth some
kind of spirit whatever it was that was
out there and Aristotle says it's got
nothing to do with us here but then you
know those philosophers that came after
they said no no not not quite what's
happening is that that ether comes into
our world penetrates our bodies and is
what forms our souls and slowly and
slowly we got more put the ether more
into religion and it wasn't until Newton
again as we can see in if we do a
revision of what I talked about
it wasn't until Newton that the ether is
brought back and this time as the
carrier of light but Newton saw it as a
medium through which the corpuscles of
light traveled the corpuscles vibrated
the ether okay and they could do so
because there was a different size in
the sin the particles that comprise the
ether versus the particles that
comprised the light and what happened
was according to Newton it was the
density of the ether that bent light
well Maxwell says you're wrong Newton
light is the vibration of the ether
ether is what's vibrating Michelson
Marnie come in what 15 years later and
is have forget you Maxwell there is no
ether we could not measure you know any
mist out there any any spirit and
whatever you want to call it we cannot
measure defeat there so we don't think
there is an ether Einstein agrees in
1905 but by 1920 he turns that around he
says forget about what I said in 1905 in
1920 says you know general relativity
cannot do without the ether but the
ether is not made of particles maybe
like Newton he was kind of criticizing
Newton there it's not made of little
particles and those particles do not
have motion the ether is a continuous
entity I guess a blocked universe
whatever he had in mind and Max Born
said oh I forget about all this ether
stuff for
about what underlies light we can't
figure it out and they went into
abstractions you know Max Born says look
we we forget about essentially they
forgot about physics and they just went
into abstractions and what comes next
well what comes next is we reinvented
the ether we have here a couple papers
and the electric universe is one of them
they believe in the ether so the ether
has not died it's still alive and well
today and that's all I can say you know
the ether is really necessary in the
sense that we need some kind of medium
for for light we need some kind of
medium for light and you could even say
we need some kind of medium for gravity
okay but for sure we need it for light
because light has the ability in the
photoelectric effect to not suppose even
according to the official version as the
ability to knock electrons get them to
move and as how it creates this current
this electricity so what hit the
electron an abstract concept the
vibration of nothing no the light has to
have some kind of medium invisible
medium that underlies it they call it
the ether but then the question is what
is the ether is it like Newton said a
bunch of particles that through which
light passes or is it like Einstein said
a continuous medium that somehow
vibrates like Maxwell said so today they
haven't figured out the ether but the
only thing that ether stands for really
in the minds of a lot of these people is
that light cannot do without a medium
light has to be the vibration of a
medium and some think of it is continue
some think of it as discrete as a bunch
of particles but you must have a medium
and then the official stance I guess I'm
not sure if it's everybody agrees with
that in the in official dumb in all of
mathematical physics but the official
stance as far as I'm concerned is that
light is the vibration of nothing there
is no medium and so we have all these
theories running around today
and with that I'll see you on Sunday
okay so toodaloo we'll see you Sunday
bye bye